IT'S TIME TO PLAY "PANDAMANIUM."
FOR MOST, THEIR 37th BIRTHDAY
CELEBRATION IS NOTHING MORE THAN
A REHEATED SLICE OF PIZZA AND
THE SOBERING REMINDER THAT THEY
ARE HALF IN THE GROUND AND
COMPLETELY IRRELEVANT TO
ADVERTISERS.
HOW WOULD I KNOW?
I'M 29.
BUT, HEY!
I HOSTED "SINGLED OUT"
WHEN I WAS 9.
BUT THAT WASN'T THE CASE WHEN
JIA JIA THE PANDA TURNED 37
YEARS OLD THIS WEEK AND BLEW UP
THE INTERNET.
JIA JIA SPENT THE DAY EATING
MORE CAKE AND BAMBOO THAN YOU
CAN SHAKE A STICK OF BAMBOO AT.
SHE WAS AWARDED THE GUINNESS
WORLD RECORD FOR OLDEST LIVING
PANDA IN CAPTIVITY.
I THINK PANDAS ARE ADORABLE.
I'M NOT A MONSTER OR A DENTIST.
SERIOUSLY, ( BLEEP ) THAT GUY.
SOMEONE SHOULD PUT THAT GUY'S
HEAD ON A PIKE.
( APPLAUSE )
>> LOOK HOW SAD THIS CAKE IS.
>> THIS, I DO--
( LAUGHTER )
>> CHRIS: I THINK THE PANDA IS
LIKE, "I SAID RED VELVET."
BEING THE OLDEST LIVING PANDA
IN CAPTIVITY IS UNIMPRESSIVE AS
FAR AS WORLD RECORDS GO.
COMEDIANS, YOUR CHALLENGE IS TO
GIVE ME SOME LESS IMPRESSIVE
GUINNESS RECORDS. I'M GONNA PUT
60 SECONDS ON THE CLOCK AND
BEGIN. KURT.
MOST WILCO PLAYED IN A COFFEE
SHOP.
>> CHRIS: POINTS. DISTEFANO.
>> MARKIEST MARK.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
KURT.
>> TENDEREST LOIN.
>> ANDY-EST DICK.
>> MOST UNCLES NAMED "RICK."
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
CHRIS.
>> BESTIEST BEST BUY.
>> CHRIS: OH, NO POINTS FROM THE
AUDIENCE ON THAT ONE.
>> LEAST CONVINCING "THAT'S WHAT
SHE SAID."
>> SIDEST BOOB.